know if they when they get married what
kind of Life do they think they're gonna
be oh that's a good question auntie go
ahead and start there
[Music]
definitely a calm wife
I know that sounds like what is a calm
wife but just someone who like keeps
their home peaceful no outside dramas
um and just
a loving nurturing place like I want
like I know in the UK you get like that
I think like 10 to 12 months or
something for your maternity leave I
want at least the two the first two and
a half yeah just with my kids at home
and I kind of want them close in age and
just
I know it sounds so like cliche and like
the cooking the cleaning bite I just
want it to be a place where my mind can
feel like he can be a man and like he's
in his role and his masculine and I can
be in my feminine and just be a mother
and a wife that's literally what I want
what do you think you're gonna get
that's what I'm going to get okay yeah
that's what I'm going to get I but I
need a man who wants to be a husband and
wants to do that role I can't have a man
who wants me to also be like so what
would your like day-to-day like life
look like if you were in that role like
what would you be doing right from one
time you wake up in the morning with the
two kids at six o'clock in the morning
what should they gonna be like well I
have my my own daily structures and then
that can just put me in the mind frame
of doing what I need to do and with kids
you know it's never good no days gonna
look the same but
what do you mean like what does it look
like a meeting Mom cooking cleaning give
us your rotor yes like all right then
you wake up at five o'clock in the
morning one baby's screaming if you've
got to get your husband ready for work
you you have a guy across from you who
makes 250 000 a year he says you know
you could be my you could be my
housewife what are you gonna do for me
go
cook clean make sure the kids are looked
after and when I say and also keep
myself together to describe your normal
day from start to finish okay so I wake
up a VJ
like get stuff out of my journal
meditate do my like seven self-care
pillars cold shower if that means I
gotta wake up at four because the kid
wants to scream at five then I gotta do
that
one two kids one might be in school one
might be Nursery or two under two I
don't know
um
homeschooled
homeschooled until what age
me doing it or like someone comes in oh
I I you know I've never
um actually thought about like what that
would look like but I would be happy to
I've never thought about what that would
look like I've always just kind of had
in my head that my kids would be at home
until about three four I personally
don't want my kids going to Nursery at
two I know that's like this is kind of
like a standard age but I I want to be
at home with my kids at two years old so
about three four they can like start
going to to other people I okay my kids
can't be looked after by other people
until they can put a sentence together
yeah like that that that's it until they
can understand like their body in terms
of like for that age they're not being
looked after by anyone and I need a man
who gets that who says you know what
yeah I agree I don't want a man to think
oh you doing that means you're going to
live off of me no I'm doing this because
of the nurturing and the foundation I
want for my kids I'm not sure because
I'm going into the world if the child is
really ill and you go to bed at midnight
are you still going to get up at four
o'clock in the morning to go for your
whole
yeah I'm just thinking myself you would
love to have that couple of hours in the
morning to do all of that all of that
stuff it just sounds amazing if they're
sick sorry sorry no I mean because
you're gonna say you're going to get up
at four o'clock in the morning if I had
because
um I was doing a lot of talking about
how do you say about your day yet it's
been a lot of
I don't know I wanna I'll tell you what
I want to hear right like you said you
get up at four o'clock in the morning
you do all of your stuff you're for you
what time's that finish
45 minutes to an hour all right then so
five o'clock we can do that
I mean I'm not a mother so I don't
exactly know what that looks like but I
know that I'm prepared to do whatever it
takes to be the mother that I know that
I want to be so I I can't how have you
how have you prepared what do you mean
no I said I I'm prepared to do it okay
so like you would have to teach you what
do you mean so you I'm saying so then he
would have to teach you you're prepared
to do it but you're not telling me what
it is yeah I I yeah I I don't know
exactly I know it takes a lot
emotionally mentally physically
um and I'm ready to and I'm prepared to
go through it and I I want to go through
it because I want to be a mother have
you got nieces and nephews
um I do do you babysit a lot not not
like that no
would you be able to if you could yeah I
could it's half term this week try it
try it for a day yeah all of them try
having them for a day yeah I would I
would let me know how you can I would be
down for it let me know how you go
I think my siblings they they range in a
massive range so I want you to have all
the ones under five
okay and let me know how you feeling for
a full day no parents involved in the
morning they drop off to the evening
bedtime I wouldn't love to do that let
me know how you get and I'd love to know
okay so then we get 5 a.m so the kids
like I don't know how long the date is
gonna be but I know it's going to be
yeah
I mean we're finding time to like have
your shower and all that and you might
not even have time to to do all of that
stuff and then to you know have dinner
ready for when he gets home like I I
know it's going to be stressful I know
it's not going to be an easy job like
I'm not even gonna pretend like I'm
deluded on that
but I just can't wait to be in it I
think you need to start practicing now
that's what I mean yeah it sounds
wonderful because I can't wait till we
get down to the end so you can hear what
it's really like
but then also great but then also I'm
how many how many meals can you cook
would you say like if you had to make a
menu of your food how many meals oh I
don't know but in the double digits okay
so like 10 20 yeah know which one 10 20
or 50.
um like 15 20 25 Okay Okay cool so he
gets 25 meals
and oh yeah no I'm just asking yeah it
gets yeah yeah okay if you have any
other questions Auntie no I just want to
know
well I know when you said I'm about um
when it gets to the end but I also know
that I won't be in that position unless
I know that he can provide a certain
lifestyle
you could never afford to have children
categorically tell you if if life
happens and we might end up in a
situation but I can get a correctly tell
you I'm not entering a situation like
that no there's no
baby leaving my body without a ring on
my finger can I come to your wedding of
course I die of course you can okay
there's nothing wrong with having kids
without marriage I mean I was born
outside of marriage but it's not
happening for me it's not
are you religious
are you religious I'm a Christian yeah
okay then that just changes things a
little bit why
before she said that's the key that's
standard chance
it's very rare now at least she's got a
there's a percentage there not very high
but this sort of percentage you don't
stand a chance for what kids no for the
the happy whatever and the regular out
there and the way the way she sounded it
just sounded like impossible yeah it
just doesn't sound like real I don't
know it depends I can't yeah
not having kids before marriage no no no
I'm gonna wake up for an hour and
meditate before my kids not meditate for
an hour oh my God no like 45 minutes no
I mean like everything that I do like
right now currently everything I do
takes about 45 minutes in the morning
that's from waking up to having my
shower meditate Vijay breakfast but well
sometime yeah oh sorry journaling it's
just where you just like get like but
it's not like happy Journey it's just
like you're getting like horrible
thoughts out and the emotions so it's
just you just get out it's done leave it
there you don't carry on into the next
day you don't carry in into the day why
wouldn't you just play pardon no I pray
as well
um and I sometimes I do it twice a day
sometimes I do it once a day it really
depends
um but I'm just I don't need to take
negative emotions from one day into the
next day and sometimes a lot of times
when you think something's happened or
someone's done you something they
actually haven't it's just you're in
your feelings and you get it out and
it's and also instead of offloading onto
another friend not all the time do I
need to call my friend about oh my God
can you believe this happen and they're
like yeah oh my God if that being just
get it out boom done move on what would
you do for your husband every day
because I've heard about the kids I've
heard about you I haven't heard about
your husband yet
like clean okay outside of that anything
else
be his support system okay how I don't
know what that look exactly what that
looks like but if he told me it looks
like x y z then it's XYZ as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible